Hello again!
In this lecture we are going to discuss the
Bernoulli distribution.
Before we begin, we use “Bern” to define
a Bernoulli distribution, followed by the
probability of our preferred outcome in parenthesis.
Therefore, we read the following statement
as “Variable “X” follows a Bernoulli
distribution with a probability of success
equal to “p””.
Okay!
We need to describe what types of events follow
a Bernoulli distribution.
Any event where we have only 1 trial and two
possible outcomes follows such a distribution.
These may include a coin flip, a single True
or False quiz question, or deciding whether
to vote for the Democratic or Republican parties
in the US elections.
Usually, when dealing with a Bernoulli Distribution,
we either have the probabilities of either
event occurring, or have past data indicating
some experimental probability.
In either case, the graph of a Bernoulli distribution
is simple.
It consists of 2 bars, one for each of the
possible outcomes.
One bar would rise up to its associated probability
of “p”, and the other one would only reach
“1 minus p”.
For Bernoulli Distributions we often have
to assign which outcome is 0, and which outcome
is 1.
After doing so, we can calculate the expected
value.
Have in mind that depending on how we assign
the 0 and the 1, our expected value will be
equal to either “p” or “1 minus p”.
We usually denote the higher probability with
“p”, and the lower one with “1 minus
p”.
Furthermore, conventionally we also assign
a value of 1 to the event with probability
equal to “p”.
That way, the expected value expresses the
likelihood of the favoured event.
Since we only have 1 trial and a favoured
event, we expect that outcome to occur.
By plugging in “p” and “1 minus p”
into the variance formula, we get that the
variance of Bernoulli events would always
equal “p, times 1 minus p”.
That is true, regardless of what the expected
value is.
Here’s the first instance where we observe
how elegant the characteristics of some distributions
are.
Once again, we can calculate the variance
and standard deviation using the formulas
we defined earlier, but they bring us little
value.
For example, consider flipping an unfair coin.
This coin is called “unfair” because its
weight is spread disproportionately, and it
gets tails 60% of the time.
We assign the outcome of tails to be 1, and
p to equal 0.6.
Therefore, the expected value would be “p”,
or 0.6.
If we plug in this result into the variance
formula, we would get a variance of 0.6, times
0.4, or 0.24.
Great job, everybody!